[Music]
hallo YouTube chess Louis in my friends
this is guns in here welcome to the 13th
episode of my dirty chest tricks against
Sicilian in this episode I'm going to
show you a wonderful tricky line in
Rosalie mo / die mono or the pulse in
variation from the white perspective the
opening arises after the following model
E for C Phi Knight to f3 Knight to c6
and now the characteristic rosalie Mamu
Bishop to b5 in the dirty chest tricks
against the seal in part 8 I have
covered the male line move g6 which if
you haven't seen it I strongly insist
you to watch it
however in this episode we are going to
concentrate on the movie 6 which
transpose back into the Thai mono or the
pulse and variation here my recognition
is you start with Knight to c3
now this position can also be reached by
a different model so let me just quickly
show you the another model which happens
after E 4 C 5 Knight to f3 and if you
open in place a 6 then you can continue
with Knight to c3 and after Knight to c6
and Bishop to b5 we pretty much reach to
the same position now as I have
highlighted over here black has 2 major
choices in this position and if you
check the online database you will find
out that here Knight G to e7 is highest
Lee played mu and that we are going to
concentrate in detail however before we
proceed there is an important trap I
like to highlight from the black
perspective that after the move Knight
to d4
[Music]
you can play any other moves except
Knight captures D for the simple reason
is after pawn captures d4 and the Moon
Knight to e2 black instantly get a
winning position with Quinn to g5 and as
you can see this queen is attacking to
spot and white cannot defend put to
think so just within sixth move of the
game black get the healthy pawn and in
fact a great deal of winning chances
okay
so let's concentrate on the move Knight
to G to e7 after that why should
certainly castle on the Kings side and
Black's idea is to play a six NAB the
bishop pair and for the lack of
development black can argue that in a
long run this asset will help him to win
the game well to some extent it's true
but due to White has a leading east
development why should open up the game
with the Moody fool and after C captures
d4 Knight captures D phone released to
the critical position of this line
now as I highlighted over here black has
two major choices
those are d6 and Queen to c7 but first
let me highlight why this Moo's are very
important as in one game
my opponent continued with Bishop to e7
which is a big-time positional mistake
as after Knight captures c6 if d capture
c6 then Bishop to f4 is a very strong
reply so as per the engine the best
movies B capture c6 but after that I can
create this nice positional grip on the
d6 square which literally cramp black
setter and what can look forward for a
pleasant middle game so in order to stop
the movie Phi here black has to play
either of this move and I'm going to
show you some cool tricks in each line
the first more I want to consider is d6
which is the second highest Lee played
more in this position which we are going
to respond with the tricky move rook to
even okay Bishop to e7 what else
black quickly wants to castle on the
Kings side and here we start our tricky
business
starting with night capture c6 pawn
captures c6 and the move Queen to g4
personally I think this is a winning
move for the white and as a valid adieu
here black has four different choices
neither of them turn out any good for
the black camp now the obvious move King
f8 is pretty bad as the rook development
will be hindered and so as the move g6
has after this white can simply continue
with Bishop two at six
and that means black king will remain in
the center for a long time so
accordingly there are two other moves
has been tried frequently and the first
move I want to consider race castle on
the Kings side
well after that white response is very
obvious Bishop - at six threatening a
checkmate and if g6 then white will
certainly grab the exchange so
accordingly black has the only defense
that is Bishop to f6 but after that
White has this decisive blow 'if i black
has two choices amongst them Bishop
captures ePHI is not even a possibility
due to the simple rook captures ePHI and
white is a piece up and still
threatening of mate so that means black
has the only move in this position D
captures ePHI afterwards white can
simply play the move rook to d1 and
white threat is very obvious no matter
wherever the Queen moves white will
continue it Knight to e4 capturing the
bishop and then threatening a mate
so accordingly black as the only decent
moon Queen to e7 staying in protection
of the bishop but what will continue
with Knight to e4 and as you can see the
simple but effective plan of the
campaign by white which is not easy to
stop fun online game between to feed a
masters continue with King to h8 which
is in fact the highest Lee played more
in this position black is simply
threatening to take the bishop so I can
drop the bishop back to e3 and amazingly
enough is still threatened to win the
exchange black come up with rook to d8
white simply exchange the rook and put
another roof on the firing line rook to
d1 black plays Queen to e7
but after Bishop to c5 I think the game
is over as when the Queen moves let's
say in the game Queen - it happens then
the simplest continuation is Knight
captures up six pawn captures up six and
now Queen to h4 attacking the loose pawn
on f6 which cannot be easily dealt in
the game black plays King to g7 but
after rook to d3 is simply resigns as
there is a checkmate in five moves so as
you can see Castle looks very obvious
but in fact is a losing move by the
black so how about Bishop to f6 and this
position which is again looks very
decent but unfortunately run straight
into our typical break yup you guessed
it 'if i well this time black has two
good options and let's see what's wrong
with them the obvious move Bishop
captures 'if i will run into the
exchange sac with rook captures e fi and
after pawn captures e5
Queen captures g7 rook to a fade and
Bishop - at six it is pretty clear
what is going to get the exchange back
with a very superior position the only
way to defend is Queen to e7 afterwards
you can capture the room and enter into
the better end game but my
recommendation is here why should
certainly grab this pawn on e5 and
continue his attack kindly note rook
cannot move if rook to g8 and then after
Knight to e4 there is a big time
disaster looming on the black king
so obviously the better move in this
position is f6 but even after this move
black is not out of the danger as after
Queen to h5 check black is forced to
block with the rook and thereafter what
will continue it rook to d1 which
creates two nasty threats Quinn to g4
and Knight to e4 and unfortunately black
cannot parry
both the threats one game in online
database between two international
master continue with Bishop to b7 so
black is trying to activate his rook
white plays the obvious move Queen to g4
threatening Queen to g8 so black
continued with Quinn to c7 giving his
King some escape route but after Queen
captures a six check Queen to e7 and
Queen back to g4 black was hoping that
white will take a draw after Queen to c7
well that's not going to happen as after
Knight to e4 threatening Knight to d6
check black calmly play rook to d8 and
thinking that there is nothing is
happening in the position but afterwards
next reply black awake from his
dreamland
before I move on I like you to pause
this video and find out what is that
winning move which create a mating net
on the black camp
well I hope you find this wonderful blow
BAM
ahahahaha superb night sacrifice which
cannot be denied
and after rook captures f6 see how
beautifully white executes the mating
sequence starting with Quinn - GA check
King to e7 Quinn captured at 7:00 check
if rook to f7 then Bishop to g4 is a
very strong reply so in the game black
continue with King to e6
now obviously you cannot capture the
Queen as your rook hang with a mate
so I'd continue with rook to even and
now indeed the Queen is hanging so
accordingly black has the only move came
to d6 and after that King moonwalk
continued on the floor with Queen to d3
check King to see if I Bishop to e3
check King to before Queen - III check
King beef I Quintus if I checked and
after King to a4 and the lovely finish
b3 I bet black player hasn't sleep that
night
now let's see a very high profile trick
in the Queen to c7 line well after that
white mu is very obvious rook to even
and once again if we check this position
in online database you will find out
that here Bishop to d6 is highest Lee
played move in this position where apart
from Bishop to d6 if you open and
continue with d6 then I have attached a
sample line in the PG n which will give
you a very good idea how to handle such
a position so let's see what we have up
in the stock after the move Bishop to d6
well here
where has this very sneaky move night to
defy which in fact forced the issue
black cannot afford to move the Queen as
I have highlighted in the arrows it has
some really nice reply so by force black
has to capture this piece and white can
capture it with the epon giving a check
and trying to regain the piece if Knight
to e7 the knight to fi is a very strong
reply so accordingly black has the only
move in this position that is Knight to
e5 okay f4 what else so white is getting
the piece back and black is more than
happy to give it back as he can castle
on the Kings side and after pawn takes
and Bishop takes what left on the board
is black has a bishop pair but he has a
structural weakness on the d7 and as the
game progresses we will see this can
create a vital factor for the white
point here why should continue it Knight
to have three attacking the bishop and
there are more than 30 games in the
database all continues with Bishop to f6
which is logical as if you play the move
Bishop to d6 then you are blocking your
deeper one and white can respond with
the MU a four with a very good position
so let's see what happens after black
plays Bishop to f6 well here comes the
key move of the whole position we are
going to continue with d6 attacking the
Queen and after Queen to c6 and Queen to
d3 white create one important point that
he blocked the D pawn and that means it
hinders the black Queen side development
so far if you are paying attention then
you have observed that this whole
sequence is pretty much force and now
again black move is very logical he
wants to develop the Queen side so the b
phi mu is obviously on the card
afterwards we will continue with Bishop
to g5
now extending the bishop will result
into the better end game for the void so
as the Queen exchange after Queen to c5
so the only logical mu in this position
is Bishop to b2 which in fact happen in
one higher rank game Bishop to b2 his
engines base choice rook to be even
Bishop to c3 and rook to e3 Black has
the only response before in order to
guard the bishop but after Bishop to e7
the trick is set right here as black
cannot move the rook in the game black
obviously played the move rook to e8 but
then white give him this ultimate shock
boom hahahaha
well obviously if you don't capture the
rook then white will grab the piece and
after Bishop captures before which
happen in the game turn out has a big
time blunder as after the following
sequence Knight to g5 threatening a
checkmate g6 preventing and now the star
mu Queen to b3 which not only hitting
the bishop but what is threatening a
checkmate and the most funny part is
black has five pieces on the board
including the Queen but still he cannot
stop the checkmate
so this is one of the wonderful
high-profile trick in Queen to c7 line
which you definitely want to consider in
the feed a rating tournament that's
guys I hope you enjoy and learn this
wonderful tricks in Sicilian rose Alamo
and or tamaño and polymerization
I have personally used this line in many
of my games and I must say even many
2000 plus rated players are falling into
this tricks well thank you for watching
this video feel free to like subscribe
and comment on this and I'll meet you in
my next episode very soon bye and take
care